hey guys this is dennis the founder of
think hero and look who's back what's
going on pink hero alumni and now with
IGN yes Roth cornet she's come into a
villain for Damon this week yeah david
is out port david because this is the
big one episode 9 is obviously always
the big one in Game of Thrones and this
did not disappoint I knew what was gonna
happen I knew what was coming I was
dreading it the entire season to some
degree it was weird looking forward to
at and ready yes what did you think um I
mean I wasn't as shocked as I like other
people probably would be that haven't
read the book just because there had
been hints in the comments section on
our reviews and stuff like that and so
but at the same time it's one of those
things where like you kind of know
what's gonna happen sure but you're like
in your mind kind of like with Ned in
the first season like oh please don't
like you think Sam Ellis up you some
somehow someone's gonna get saved
there's something like that but now well
they have made you know certainly there
have been changes made from the bus to
the show and probably more this season I
think than any other season but I knew
they weren't going to change to this no
I mean they're not going to change
something as traumatic as this is called
the red wedding in the books and and it
was going to happen I was almost I was
looking forward to seeing the reactions
on Twitter almost as much as watching
the episodes no um and it was about as
devastating as I thought it was going to
be they kind of lulled you into a sense
of security because this episode itself
was actually kind of slow yeah the home
the whole one hour like and not until
like the last 10 minutes did anything
actually happen and a lot of stuff
happened yeah and that was sort of
interesting for me too because here's
the thing that's different than black
water and then I think was even
different than sort of f9a season one
when Ned Stark is that there was a no
there was a way story wise to introduce
levels of tension because you knew that
this for instance with Blackwater you
knew that a battle was going to happen
you maybe didn't know what the outcome
of the battle is going to be but you
knew that a battle was coming and so if
you have conversations sort of myth you
know thoughtful conversations between
Thursday and Sansa that's
still filled with tension because and
then certainly when you have seriously
with her child possibly about to kill
her child there's a level of tension
with this one it's all about the sucker
punch yeah you don't see it coming I
mean ideally if you don't know it's
coming you don't see it coming you don't
see it coming everything looks fine
everything's Mary okay good we have the
phrase on our side BAM yeah once I heard
the music play I was like oh shits about
to go down I was really impressed with
that you guys Dennis it was just a field
notes in and and in into the song and he
goes oh and he recognized the song and
he knew if they're playing the Lannister
song right now what is essentially the
Lannister seeing the rains of castamere
something ain't right yeah and Lord
Bolton is a bastard indeed yeah him and
Walter Frey it's like man it's like how
was how I didn't think I was fine
someone that would hate more than
Joffrey but at this point like they've
won up Joffrey in a way in a way I think
it's it's two sides I mean certainly for
Bolton it's really more of a calculated
thing you know he understands that the
Starks are in a good position you know
they've made a few tactical errors and
and they're just not in a good position
any longer and he's going with team
Lannister because he feels like teen
Lannisters gonna win and that's it you
know he he is a calculated cold night I
can at least understand that more than I
can with Walter frame because his was
like all just basically you wronged me
you shamed me and now I'm getting my
revenge you know yeah I I think it's
overkill basically I mean I understand
why I mean I understand why he's upset
but the reaction is just you know uh you
know that what they did was like this
what he did is like like that yeah I
mean I think I think again it's part
it's a little bit of both you know I
think he is so insulted and he's so
angry and he's so embittered and and he
and this is his response you know
full-scale slaughter and he has broken a
long tradition when he said that he gave
them
action that is like a sacred vow that he
made to to their gods he made a sacred
vow it's never been broken and that's
why they felt safe yeah I mean they
really this is so shocking what he's
done I mean it's such a massive upheaval
in that world yeah and they also he made
them feel safe also you know that's kind
of when I was like oh something's up
when we in a Lord enemy had they
revealed like the pretty wife or
whatever that he was gonna marry which I
don't know you there were some really
funny moments in there as well like that
look between here Rob like mmm yeah and
so like that when that happened I like
something's up cuz yeah that's you know
that's too good to be true types of
stuff yeah well certainly for Game of
Thrones in it you know and again like I
think in season one with Ned there was
all the intrigue happening and the
positioning over who was gonna be king
and and sort of how they were gonna
handle that and so you had all of that
ten you know and dad being right you had
all that tension one place that I do
feel that that they were able to utilize
and build some tension was with Aria
yeah first of all just because she she
is in sort of a she is in a perilous
situation but also that conversation
between her and the hound um worked
beautifully to demonstrate more aspects
to her psyche you know like she is she
is brutal but she is also very
compassionate yeah and then she says oh
you're too nice it's gonna get to you
and then she knocks out the guy yeah
like basically saying yeah I'm kind of
nice but not that nice she's basically
like don't worry about it yeah you know
and I'm gonna put and she says it's so
simply I'm gonna put a sword through
your eye and everything back of your
skull I was just so awesome as user but
I think that because she's a little girl
they were able to create some and
because the Hound is so volatile and he
is a killer when she has his back to him
and things like that they're able to
create some such attention you don't
know what he's really gonna do when he's
really gonna lose his temper if she
threatens him a fire but also because he
points out you're so close to your goal
you've been looking for your family this
long you're so close and you're afraid
you're not going to get it well that
makes us afraid yes write it and then
what happens is worse than even worse
than her not reaching her
family it's basically she already
experienced one traumatic experience
before with her father and now this is
the second one she didn't get to see it
but she's gonna find out what happened
yeah I mean this girl has had such a
rough time of it and I mean it's really
interesting because Arya's love becomes
hate like that you know a really she
loves so deeply and she was so loyal but
if you wrong her if you hurt the one she
loves she's never gonna forget it no
never ever ever no and I'm not spoiling
anything and this is all in her
character I have to say as an animal
lover it is almost if not I'm not gonna
say harder but it's almost hard to watch
the wolf get kill I mean it really is so
painful to me that's defect it's it's
defenseless and so seeing that is but
yeah but I mean still like you have with
with raw catlin and rob's rock yeah life
with the pregnant you did the baby
stabbing that's like when you knew all
bets were off yeah absolutely and here's
the thing and I hesitate I don't like to
do too many comparisons to the books
because um if you're gonna read them
then you'll have something new to enjoy
um but everyone knows that this the wife
Rob's wife is a different character on
the show than in the books now we may
know why hey you know I mean because
there was still something in there to
shock us and to sort of shake us up in
that scene there's a little little
difference in sort of catlins behavior
that some people may be bothered by I'm
not um I think what do you think about
the fact that she became a killer I mean
she like Aria I think maybe that's where
Aria gets it from like she loves her
family so much that like something you
know going through the trauma of Ned and
now this like that's her firstborn son
mm-hmm like that that took her over the
edge I mean she you know she could have
recovered from his his wife being killed
but she couldn't come back from her son
yeah and she already lost her husband
her firstborn son that's it I
she could have freaked out she could
have screamed she could have really
openly gone crazy but there was
something in the total silence and
acceptance at the coming of her death
that I think worked and then the silence
mm-hmm in the credits yes you know just
sit there and think about it he I was
looking at him he was just going yes cuz
you can't you can't put that to music
nothing like the shock of it you can't
you know there's no like music that fits
what just happened I mean silence is the
perfect music to to that ending I'm
curious like does this affect your
viewing of this series now that that Rob
is no longer a player in this I mean
that's what's so great about this series
is that they've created so many
characters that you either root for root
against that even though a character
character or characters that you liked
died you could you still go on it's like
with the first season Ned died we all
like most people like this character but
there's so many other ones that you can
attach ourselves to that you could just
move on and like not like you're not
you're still gonna miss them but there's
just too much intrigue and too many good
characters that you want to see what
happens and also you want to see you
want to see the people that you hate get
theirs once you Joffrey get his you know
see Lord Bolton get his you want to see
Walter Frey get his yeah oh yeah yes
does this affect at all who you think
should were you rooting for Rob did you
think Rob would win wait on the game of
thrones I thought he should win I mean
personally I'm a big fan of Tyrion Arya
Arya is not old enough yet Tyrion he
kind of needs to get into maybe
something different than the Lannisters
and his family you know get some sort of
power that way Danny I'm also rooting
for as well but no I mean I mean I liked
Rob but uh he kind of had similar traits
to his father that that led to his
downfall and I think I think that's
where aria maybe in the future which she
gets older will succeed because she's
she doesn't you
no fall for some of that that stuff and
I think that it's interesting i think
that scene with the hounds sort of
Illustrated that where she can have that
stark sense of compassion you know but
she won't let it what happens it's such
an interesting thing is that Ned and Rob
had this sense of right and wrong that
was unbendable if they decided that
something was ethically right or wrong
that's what they did unbendable you know
both bet you know you killed a man that
you sentence you kill the man if you
sent into it doesn't matter if it's the
right political move and that I think
was really their undoing you know and
we're not playing the game of thrones
that's the thing they're in it but
they're not playing he's a great it's
weird too because he's such a good
strategist in terms of like as a warrior
but some he needed a little bit more of
a calculated edge when I came to sort of
the political maneuverings that undid
both of them and then also frankly that
the a little bit of luck undid both of
them because they both happen to run
into people like you mentioned that were
just crazy enough to kill them yeah when
they shouldn't have I mean Joffrey
shouldn't have killed Ned no and listen
you saw the preview saw the previews for
next week tyrion knows he said it the
north will never forget yeah this is
this is wow this is going to you know
there's there's no more like oh well
we'll just follow whoever you know the
Lannisters put up as king and whatnot
yeah it's it's done it's done with so
tell me what did you think about brands
sort of discovery of the the nature of
his ability what I liked about this
episode it was like how brand and his
story line connected with Jon Snow's and
we already talked about how with Rob and
catlin there's connected with Orion so
it was cool to see bran and his powers
and and now we see like why he's so
special because before it was like okay
you know you do a little dreams of like
beg for shadowing but now it's like okay
he has a real power real power that
actually helps sure right I can get into
a wolf and have the wolf kill people for
one thing but the real thing that he can
do you know as
they say you get into a human's mind
which no one else can do yeah everyone
up like other words can do the get into
the animal thing but he's only one I can
get into humans well an imagine imagine
the power that it would give you to
control a human being what human being
would you choose to control what would
you have that human being to I mean
certainly in in some some hands that
power could be limitless you know the
options for what you could do you could
go into the heads of kings and queens
and make them do things you wanted them
to do potentially potentially I don't
know we don't know how much power we
don't we don't know I'm not spoiling
anything i'm speculating about his power
um but it is interesting certainly it's
a new development and well thank God
that he he has that stark sense of honor
right because here he is protecting his
brother immediate they do the right
thing as much as they can you know as
much as they can I mean bowling issue
was that he doesn't know that him and
great are in love so he just had some
runoff yeah and not knowing that now you
grits like what a traitor that bastard
you know and so that's going to cause a
lot of tension the next time those two
see each other ah and also you know now
we know that rakhana is gonna go with
OSHA OSHA yes and and then Hodor and
brighter we're gonna keep going on and
so we're gonna see that split now yeah
okay I mean there's like a I don't want
to get into the changes but but I really
enjoyed I really enjoyed the reveals of
this episode I really enjoyed the way
the way that bran is coming into his own
because I feel like as he learns more
about his power he also becomes more and
more of the leader and man that he is
maybe meant to be you know and and
listen maybe that phone was meant to
happen yeah and also wasn't a call it
was a pleasure personally like for this
season his story let hasn't really
interests me until now yeah like now
it's like okay this is what he's about
and this is this bodes well for the
future of his character but throughout
this whole season they kind of just
you know little scenes here and there on
the side and you know but now he finally
has something to do well just out of
curiosity do you feel like John should
have revealed do you think you should
have killed that man just to stay in the
position that he was in with the
Wildings for a bit longer um speaking of
the Starks and the way they do things
yeah I mean he even though he doesn't
have the stark name he is he's still his
father son and he just he couldn't do it
yeah it's like he couldn't kill a grin
yeah I couldn't do this and and you know
in this case I don't think it's that big
of a deal because eventually he was
gonna have to break free of it and
reveal himself anyways it probably was
earlier than he expected but i think it
was inevitable yeah well i mean i think
listen i think that there are some
people that are feeling like oh most of
the episode was slow and then it's this
big ending true enough but i think it
was still rich yeah you know with sort
of development and movement for the
characters yeah and I also think this
season unlike I haven't seen next
episode but unlike the previous two
seasons where episode 9 was the big
thing and then 10 was kind of like
almost like a prologue to set up season
the next season yeah I think this one is
almost like a two-parter oh yeah like I
feel like next episode is not gonna be
that prologue where things calm down and
and they set up for next season yeah I
think it's gonna be an additional
shitstorm of stuff coming I'm not gonna
say anything but I'm gonna say if you
can avoid the comments do please don't
leave spoilers in the comments but you
guys tune in next week because yeah
there's if they're gonna do the things
that they may do boy is there still more
stuff to come and let's just talk
briefly about Danny I mean we didn't see
too much of that we just kind of saw the
whole thing where she's taking over that
City but they didn't really show much of
it they just kind of showed a little
more tension between Jorah Mormont and
the new guy Darien mmn and kind of just
his jealousy of dairying cuz you know
was over there and grabs her hand yeah
and she can tell that Danny is attracted
to this guy oh sure I mean he looks like
Fabio listen not the Fabio but that is
one of the other things that I think
book readers have had an issue with he
looks very different um in the show than
he was described at like remarkably
different um ok I understand sort of the
reasons that they did I think with Danny
right now I mean they're having to
they're having to find different ways to
keep characters relevant who they're
having to stretch certain things out
there having to find certain ways to
keep characters relevant that may have
been irrelevant now that yeah I mean
Danny was in the book but there are
books there are books that certain
characters are missing for you know and
so I I mean I feel like this episode for
Danny was just again like like you said
a build-up you know into the world of
the show it's just her amassing more and
a little bit it's her becoming more of a
leader and one of the ways that she
learns to become a leader is to endow
leadership I mean you're only really a
good leader if you empower other people
to do what they're meant to do as well
you know and so the moment that she says
to him you know to grey worm you're a
leader now so what do you think and she
she trusts him she trust his judgment
she's empowering him and she's sort of
creating she's creating her army what
she's gonna do with that army we don't
know and she wants she doesn't want just
an army she wants a loyal army yeah
that's fighting for something not just
not fighting for her not fighting for
her glory yeah but they were fighting
for money they're fighting because they
want to fight yeah for the cause basic
yeah and I mean to be honest with you
and and and some people have problem
like some people problems with Danny in
the show some people rawlins with Danny
and book to me I really feel like she is
especially given how young she is in the
world of this world you know she is
really finding the best way possible to
learn how to be a leader and she is
finding that balance of I yeah I need an
army
that is strong that is mighty that I can
control but they have to be loyal or
they'll betray me yeah I mean look at
what happened to her dad and we know why
it happened to her dad now and Jamie was
justified but still yeah that's gonna
stick with you yeah so it was another
great episode it obviously was slow and
I think slow on purpose mm-hmm for the
first you know eighty percent of it and
then just to lure you into that sense of
security and then punch you in the
stomach punch you in the face yeah punch
you in the heart my god like I'm still
reeling from it I was looking forward to
this I am really looking forward to next
week and and I will leave your comments
and I'm looking forward to hearing what
and seeing what people have to say about
it if you knew if you didn't know were
you happy were you not please don't
spoil anything yes and but please do
leave your comments i'm gonna read them
all right guys before before we go I
want to let you guys know that we are
actually moving channels right now this
is the thing here of TV channel and
we're starting a new channel as a think
hero pro so make sure you subscribe to
that channel we're going to keep on
doing the reviews and we're gonna do
other videos and stuff like that and
I'll put the link below in the cup and
the description and also right here you
can click on it and yeah you can leave
comments on this YouTube video on the
website you can fall us on Twitter mine
is acting hero mine is my name Roth
cornet at Roth cornet yeah and you also
can find a ross work on IGN happy you
can find my work on IGN every day and we
also have a Facebook page that's a
facebook.com slash think Carol fans see
you guys later thanks guys
you